I want I want I want Andy Reid to get a
ring yeah yeah Sean did a great job of
just compiled turning on color rush
uniforms yeah I mean he just he did
everything he could wear here's
something both these teams next year the
Saints that was Drew Brees with his two
weeks ago in Miami we busted him he
prematurely admitted that he is coming
back we are playing the 49ers in the
Chiefs next year and look he said a
couple of weeks ago he's gonna take a
month or so and make a decision about
whether or not he will return he's only
gonna return for the Saints nobody else
I think he'll be back I don't think he's
gonna retire but until he says so for
sure this isn't one of those Ben
Roethlisberger attention ploys all due
respect Ben this is drew Brees
seriously contemplating whether or not
he's going to return so we lead off the
first topic of what's more likely with
Drew Brees and another guy who
definitely will be changing teams if he
continues his NFL career and that's
Philip Rivers which quarterback is more
likely to play two more years Shireen is
it drew Brees or Philip Rivers well I
don't think either one of them is going
to play two more years I think this is
gonna be the last year for both but if I
have to pick one I'm gonna go with Drew
Brees I just think he's playing better
at his age and I know he's what three
years older than Philip Rivers but he's
playing better at his age than Philip
Rivers is it his Philip Rivers had tied
for the second-most interceptions he
ever thrown worst passer rating since
2012 I just didn't think he had a good
year and I don't know how much he has
left and and Brees doesn't have a lot
left either I understand that but I just
think he's playing at a higher level has
a better team around him and maybe
Rivers goes somewhere and proves me
wrong because he has more talent
somewhere else but if I'm gonna pick one
I'm gonna pick Drew Brees despite him
being older than Philip Rivers I agree
with you you know my first thought was
well Philip Rivers says he wants to play
two more years but he said a maximum of
two more years and I think he's gonna
have a hard time
a team that will hand him the keys to
the car without any question competition
possibility of drafting a rookie who
would take over for Philip Rivers and
the contract that would have to go along
with Philip Rivers being the guy I don't
think it's gonna be as automatic as some
do with Brees it's all up to him if he
wants to stay this year they want him if
he wants to stay next year they'll want
him they'll make it work now they are
gonna have to deal with Taysom Hills
contract because they do believe you
know everybody likes to go nuts on the
idea that some think Taysom Hill is a
franchise quarterback there are plenty
of people who don't well I'll tell you
who does the Saints think that he can be
a franchise quarterback and at some
point they want to turn the page from
Brees to Hill but I think between Brees
and rivers Brees is indeed more likely
to play two more years although I bet
the under Sharia non both guys if it
came down to it all right which and this
one on the surface I looked at and I
said why is this here and then I thought
about it's like oh okay wait a minute
this one makes some sense which receiver
is more likely to get the franchise tag
AJ Green of the Bengals or Amari Cooper
of the Cowboys and the reason I thought
it was a little silly it's like wait a
minute we know Dax getting the franchise
tag but maybe he doesn't maybe they get
a deal done with dak and they slap that
tag on Amory Cooper and I guarantee you
if they get a deal done with dak Cooper
is getting that tag so which is more
likely to get tagged
Shareen green or cooper well I don't
think they get a deal done with that
Prescott so I think they're gonna use
the franchise tag on dak Prescott and
then we'll use the other tag the
transition tag on Amari Cooper there
they can't let Amari Cooper walk away
they've traded a first-round draft pick
for him they finally found a franchise
receiver to replace Dez Bryant which
they hadn't seen from Dresden since 2014
and they finally feel like they have
that guy and they have dak Prescott and
Amari Cooper and Ezekiel Elliott and
they have their triplets again so
they're not gonna let Amari Cooper walk
away but I just don't think they're
gonna be able to use that franchise tag
because of the fact that dak Prescott is
also scheduled to become a free agent
and I don't think they get this deal
done in time to use the franchise tag on
a Mauri Cooper
yeah I agree
with you on that completely I don't
think they're gonna get a deal done and
you know a part of that urgency to get a
deal done with Zach is to use the
franchise tag on Amory Cooper and and
that's part of the reality that Dec has
been pushing back against he's pushing
back against everything the Cowboys are
trying to do to convince him to do it
and I'm sure at some point along the way
Steven Jones or Jerry Jones have said to
dak or his representatives we'd like to
get this deal done so we can tag Amari
Cooper and their reaction that I presume
has been that's not our problem that's
your problem
so I think AJ green far more likely to
be franchise tag and also as it relates
to the Bengals they don't want to make a
long-term financial commitment to AJ
green but they don't want to lose AJ
green yet so I could see them being
willing to tie up a fairly significant
chunk of the salary cap on AJ Green for
one more year and it would be one more
year and and I also think there's a
possibility Green gets traded during the
2020 season under that franchise tag
maybe they just see how the season goes
if it looks like things are going well
they keep him if the season falls apart
early then I think he becomes a guy that
could be traded with that franchise tag
salary applied to him all right which
free agent running back is more likely
to sign a new deal first Derrick Henry
of the Titans or Melvin Gordon of the
Chargers yeah I thought this was a good
one but I'm gonna go with Melvin Gordon
since he is a free agent and we think
he's gonna get a deal coming up the
thing is I don't think Melvin Gordon's
gonna get the contract that he thinks
he's going to get of course he held out
last year wanting that big new contract
and I just don't think it's going to be
what he thinks it's going to be what you
see what's happened with Todd Gurley
with the deal he signed and hasn't lived
up to that Ezekiel Elliott did not have
as good of a year this year after
holding out and and coming back and
playing it just wasn't as good of a year
and so I think teams are seeing that hey
we can win with some running backs that
we don't have to pay this huge money to
so I just don't know who's gonna go out
and and pay Melvin Gordon what he thinks
he's worth he's gonna get a good deal I
just don't think it's gonna be what he
thinks it's going to be and in the
Titans you know they've got a signed
Derrick Henry and eventually maybe he's
going to hold out what
it happens there but there's not that
urgent see that there is with Melvin
Gordon since he is a free agent to sign
I think he's gonna sign I don't know
that he's gonna sign the first day of
free agency but I think he's gonna sign
fairly early and free agency you know
ordinarily I would say if a team has a
running back and a quarterback both of
whom are due to become free agents it's
the quarterback who would be franchise
tag but in Tennessee between Derrick
Henry and Ryan Tannehill with all the
other options that are out there at
quarterback I think that the Titans are
more likely to use the franchise tag on
Derrick Henry which would make him less
likely to sign a new deal before Melvin
Gordon who as you said will be a free
agent will be in a position where he can
sign a deal early now it could be that
he hates the offers that he gets so much
that he decides to wait which would be a
mistake you're never gonna get more
money than you're gonna get in those
first few days of free agency so you
have to have your agent ready to go out
there in the middle of that land rush
and stake a flag in the ground and get
you the most possible money that he can
but I think that's the one thing that
has me hesitate on Gordon there is a
chance Gordon's just gonna say no I
don't want any of these deals but he's
gonna be in position to sign a deal
before Henry because Gordon is going to
be on the market Henry's gonna get the
franchise tag which is gonna be about
ten or eleven million dollars which is a
heck of a lot more than he's ever made
but you know it's not that long term
long term big money payday that he's
going to want but you're right the
performance of his ego Elliot I think is
going to cause the Titans to maybe shy
away from making a long-term major
commitment and Derrick Henry because the
last thing you want to do is give a
running back big money and all really
end up paying them for things they've
already done not things that they're
doing now and in the future
yeah that's absolutely right and you
know with with Elliot the fact that he
held out you don't want your running
back holding out you especially don't
want your quarterback holding out which
we think Cowboys have with potentially
with that Prescott but we saw it with
Eliot he trained and supposedly trained
really hard in Cabo and it just isn't
the same thing and when he came back he
wasn't the same guy for whatever reason
and maybe that was part of it but you
you want your guys in camp and so to do
that they either need to accept the
franchise tag or you need to get a
long-term deal done to have the team you
think you're gonna have and have those
players ready to go when the season
starts Ryan Tannehill potentially not
returning to Tennessee is just another
one of those those examples of the chaos
that could be coming in this year's
quarterback free agency carousel and any
other year we it would be possibly the
biggest story the offseason but with so
many other names so many of the guys
it's just kind of a mid-level story this
year but it's got huge ramifications for
the Titans because if they don't have
Tannehill they need somebody else which
veteran tight end is more likely
returned for another season jason witten
most recently with the Cowboys or Greg
Olson most recently with the Panthers I
really thought Jason Witten who was
going to retire for good and go into
coaching but the Giants and the Cowboys
both have filled those coaching
vacancies at tight ends and I guess they
could get him in as some sort of
offensive assistant or something along
those lines but I really think at this
point that he's coming back that if he
didn't commit to becoming a coach I'm
sure he's training and getting ready
that I think Jason Witten is going to
come back and play again might not be
with the Cowboys I think it's probably
more likely to be with the Giants he'll
follow his former head coach Jason
Garrett to the Giants but I think he is
going to play another season and Greg
Olson you know I think there's a chance
he could go into TV I think he's
weighing that right now I know he they
said he might have a decision today but
TV seems to be calling his name so I'm
gonna go with Jason Witten on this one
because I think he's committed to
playing another year I think it's gonna
be Greg Olson he's in the
process of visiting with teams and Fox
likes him enough that they will put a
pin in it for one more year as it
relates to him doing NFL games he's
doing xfo games now getting good reviews
for that he'll probably do them again
next year and then that leads into him
being part of their NFL coverage come
2021 all right speaking of the XFL what
is more likely to last longer the XFL or
Tim Tebow's remaining pace Paul career
I'm gonna go with the XFL on this one I
mean Tebow is struggling there at the
triple-a level I think it says a lot
about him and his athleticism that he's
able to make it this far but that
batting average is under the Mendoza
line and his age he's getting up there
and it's in his young 30s and and that's
getting up there when you have it played
in the major leagues yet so the XFL is
gonna be around at least two years and
the way it looks I think people have
kind of bought in I'm hearing a lot of
people say hey did you watch the XFL on
the first weekend now the second weekend
and the third weekend to me or the key
weekends or people still going to tune
in in that second home game that these
teams have are people still going to
show up at the stadium or was it just a
novelty a one-week thing but I people
are starting to kind of talk about the
XFL right now at least around here and
so I think that's a good sign for the XF
Fell's long-term future I'm tempted to
say t-bo's baseball career though just
because it shouldn't have lasted as long
as it has and and there's a business
reason for it he he sells tickets
he sells jerseys he creates excitement
people want to come out and see him play
whatever level of the minor leagues he's
at and I feel like based upon some
things that were said by Mets executives
within the past two years it's just a
matter of time before they wedge him on
to the Mets in September when they do
the call ups when the rosters expand or
or just find a spot for him get him on
get him on get if it gets an extra 5,000
people to show up every game then it's
worth it and I don't know that it would
be quite that many on a regular basis
but my point is this is ultimately an
entertainment business and if you can
attract more people to your to your
ballpark on a given day because you have
to
Tibo there's value in that but I'm still
gonna go with the XFL I'm Shireen I am
trying not to get emotionally invested
in the XFL I have been a naysayer
I have pooh-poohed it I don't want to
get my heart broken again I don't want
to get myself fired up about a sports
league a football league that that can
be very entertaining they could be a
nice little a nice little respite from
the NFL I I just I guess it'll be the
XFL I guess it will be I just hope it
doesn't last long enough for me to say
I'm all-in with the XFL and then it
disappears that's what I fear is gonna
happen we'll find out whether or not
that happens
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports